hi princess hi Lindsay so have you ever
done the fanfiction before yes many
moons ago oh yeah what was the first
fandom you have a wrote for uh Avatar
The Last Airbender satara lives on
forever mm-hmm what about you phantom
phantom of the opera' like not the Billy
Zane phantom the the bad one the
problematic one so on a scale from
disappointed to dishearten how deep is
your shame my shame um pretty deep how
about you um you know sometimes I feel
shamed but other times I'm like you know
what I like my trash hmm and that is
what we are trying our relationship to
fanfic as a concept has changed but not
just fans relationship to it the
professional publishing world also has a
wildly different relationship to fanfic
even from like ten years ago so what has
caused this shift and what does that
change
even look like part of the human
fascination with narrative is a desire
to expand on the stories we hear one
popular narrative is the story of the
trickster hero like in the American
South we have the jak tale about a guy
named Jack or in the black diaspora we
have the spider god character Anansi
these characters have no original author
but over the years have gained
popularity in their communities through
oral traditions but the modern concept
of copyright complicates our
relationship to characters and
narratives which are no longer the
intellectual property of a culture
they're the IP of a person or a company
fanfiction website archive of our own or
I lost a Hugo to last year co-founder
Francesca Coppa defines it simply as
creative material featuring characters
from works whose copyright is held by
others there's kind of an unspoken
understanding that you aren't supposed
to make money off of fanfiction which is
part of why copyright holders usually
let it slide and as a result it kind of
exists in this legal gray area most IP
owners let it exist and some even
encourage it because it facilitates a
good relationship with fans but for me
what's really interesting about fan
fiction is the negative connotations
that have sort of dogged it over the
last few decades that fan fiction is in
that it's neither real writing nor a
good writing exercise that it is
something to be relegated to the
daydreams of preteen girls but not only
that professional author's relationship
to fanfiction has changed many authors
began as fan fiction writers and are
kind of out-and-proud about that now
some continue to write it for fun and
sometimes they just swap out the names
of the copyrighted characters and
publish their fanfic as original fiction
where fan fiction used to be seen as a
joke writers today have been coming out
of the closet so to speak about their
own history with fan fiction and how it
helped them form their professional
careers that's right
we have Hugo and nebula winning fanfic
authors now some history what we know is
fan fiction has its roots not on the
internet but in fanzines specifically
science fiction fanzines from the early
20th century which actually published
fanfiction at the time to Harvard
English professor and writer dr.
Stephanie Burt fan fiction is a
phenomenon that has always existed in
some form or other as a way for fans to
meaningfully interact with the media
they liked says Burt first there were
fans of science fiction novels and
magazines who held conventions and
traded self-published journals as early
as the 1930s or first there was Sherlock
Holmes whose devotees hooked by serial
publication pushed for more stories
formed clubs and wrote their own some
say that fan fiction itself isn't
writing that real writers don't
participate in it that if you want to
write you have to have original stories
you know like James Joyce and William
Shakespeare and Dante and Salman Rushdie
says Bert again no clearer path from new
writers to potentially interested
readers has existed in the history of
civilization not all stories are stories
that other people will seek out if you
can work your memories hypotheses or
fantasies about living away from home or
gender transition or about retirement
into a story about Bruce Wayne and Dick
Grayson
maybe the many people who care about
Batman and Robin will care about your
thoughts and experiences too this
challenges the idea that fan fiction is
the toy of the creatively bereft that
the only good fiction is brightest 100%
original why for example is John
Milton's Paradise Lost or James Joyce's
Ulysses canon without ever questioning
their originality
they're just retellings of the Bible and
the Odyssey respectively well part of it
is copyright Cheng keenest Ulysses in
Paradise Lost are based on stories that
were never copyrighted because copyright
was not a thing in homers time we have a
wholly different relationship to copy
right now than James Joyce and John
Milton did but that can't be all of it
ever since modern fan fiction gained
popularity and fanzines particularly
Star Trek fan scenes it's predominantly
been the wheel house of women
best-selling author and Hugo winner Sean
and Maguire sees the phenomenon as
partially a response to a lack of female
oriented storytelling and mainstream and
published mediums in her essay the
bodies of the girls who made me fan
fiction in the modern world
she writes everyone who grows up on a
diet of Western media learns on some
level to accept the default as their
avatar because we historically haven't
had much choice want to be the hero
instead of the love interest the scrappy
sidekick or the villain embraced the
default learn to have empathy with the
default he's what you get we stopped
writing about ourselves and started
writing avatars characters who could
represent us in the stories without
quite being us it's no coincidence that
a large part of the fanfiction community
has been built by women PLC and LGBTQ
writers in a professional publishing
world that is only relatively recently
begun to represent them fan fiction is
having something of a reckoning over the
last few years
writers like Sean and Maguire or NK
jemisin
successful authors who are vocal
proponents of what fan fiction has meant
to them as creative minds or websites
like archive of our own creating a
living documentation of fan fictions
vast community while advocating for free
speech or academics like Francesca Coppa
publishing both commercial fanfiction
and research on the subject
Star Trek fandom was the starting point
for many science fiction professional
writers Jacqueline Lichtenberg was an
early Star Trek fan tech writer she went
on to publish her own fantasy series
starting in 1974 and lois mcmaster
bujold one of the most prolific and
beloved science-fiction writers still
writing today and writer in the door
closing in saga also dabbled in Trek fan
works early in her career but these are
early examples of professional authors
getting their start and fan works which
is not the same thing as repackaging
your fan fiction
original fiction and then publishing it
when fictional fan works are rewritten
and sold as pro '[ __ ] the finish code
for this is filing off the serial
numbers Fifty Shades of Grey which
originated as Twilight fan fiction might
be the cliche of fan fiction reworked
for publication but it's actually been a
thing for a while there are a few
obscure incidences from the olden times
for instance in 1985 author Terry White
published a Starsky and Hutch fanfic as
cowboy blues and in 1997 author shoes in
Matthews we worked her Star Wars fan
fics
into an exchange of hostages and the
jurisdiction series you love to see it
but since the 2000s perhaps in no small
part because publishers have taken note
of fanfic authors who already have big
followings of their own it's gone from
anomaly to actual trend Cassandra Clare
was a Harry Potter and Lord of the Rings
BNF which for those not in fandom
parlance no means big name fan she
became hugely popular in Harry Potter
fandom for her draco trilogy much of
which was reworked into her best-selling
Mortal Instruments series and a shocking
amount of one fanfic sub genre called
RPF which means real person Vic which is
exactly what it sounds like has been
reworked for publication probably
because you can't really like copyright
a person so there's a lot less copyright
jank there you can just write about a
real person and pretend it's a fictional
character after is the most famous
example of this reworked from the fanfic
of the same name about a college
alternate universe or a you featuring
Harry Styles from one direction as a bad
Harry Styles but there's a truly
staggering amount of One Direction
fanfic that has had its serial numbers
filed off for publication so not only
are some authors permissive of
fanfiction
even starting their careers as fanfic
writers before making the transition
some just cut out the middleman and
published their slightly reworked
fanfiction as original fiction
JK Rowling has been generally supportive
of fan fiction but not all authors have
such a benign relationship to the
concept of fan fiction authors who
aren't so keen on fanfic rage from the
mildly disapproving like uncle george RR
martin who said my characters are my
children i don't want people making off
with them thank you even people who say
they
love my children I'm sure it's true I
don't doubt the sincerity of the
affection but still no one gets to abuse
the people of Westeros but me and the
writers of Game of Thrones and that
brings us to Vampire Chronicles author
Anne Rice who was once very hardcore
with the whole cease and desist letter
thing to the point where pretty much the
entirety of Vampire Chronicles
fanfiction throughout the 90s and 2000's
existed on lockdown live journal groups
with some fans even claiming to have
been harassed by Isis lawyers the
characters are copyrighted it upsets me
terribly to even think about fanfiction
with my characters I advise my readers
to write your own original stories with
your own characters it is absolutely
essential that you respect my wishes
yeah that's my that's my Anne Rice voice
although to her credit she has mellowed
out a little since then even pro authors
like Shauna and McGuire who continued to
write fanfic themselves would prefer
that you don't send your own to them
because it could muddy the waters of
whose idea is whose sudden McGuire in a
tweet from 2017 fanfic is awesome and
amazing and I love it
and if you try to tell me about your
fanfic I will shut you down like a
Blockbuster Video some authors have
cited a 1992 incident involving author
Marion Zimmer she was initially very
supportive of fandom and fan fiction in
particular but while writing a new novel
she realized that it touched on themes
of a fanfiction she had already read
Bradley decided to scrap the novel
altogether rather than risk a lawsuit so
where fanfic used to exist mostly in the
underground in the realm of pure hobby
ISM and sometimes in locked livejournal
communities out of fear of litigious
authors fan fictions emergence into the
mainstream has changed our relationship
to it professional authors are fine
admitting their past and sometimes
present as fan fiction writers it's no
longer this shameful activity done in
shadow but an activity that is
recognized as a valid way to improve
your skills as a writer as Neil Gaiman
puts it I think that all writing is
useful for honing your writing skills I
think you get better as a writer by
writing and whether that means you are
writing a singularly deep and moving
novel about the pain or pleasure of
modern existence or you're writing a
smegal Gotham slash Vic you're still
putting one damn word after another and
learning as a writer and that is my best
Neil Gaiman impression how did you know
about my Smeagol Gollum slash McNeal
Gaiman cease-and-desist